[Music]
this is a new organic light-emitting
diode screen from Samsung it's hot off
the presses from Korea it doesn't have a
name or a price or anything like that
yet it's 14 inches right now they kind
of attach it to his laptop as you can
see it's transparent it's actually 40
percent transparent we turn it on you
get this this is freakin amazing this
may have looks like a prop from Avatar
but it's not this is real you get a
hundred thousand to one contrast ratio
you see it's still transparent you can
see my hand moving in the background and
it has all kinds of cool applications
you can use it for like a car windshield
put your speedometer and your radio
station and things like that on it or
thanks for the medical profession or
even like in your office like your
cubicle your walls could actually be
made out of this and you could like see
right through it but also have like your
data and stuff like out on as well just
be clear this is still an RD you can't
buy this technology yet but really
excited to see how it's going to turn
out in the future
[Music]
you